Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192. David P. Take a listen
to this voicemail about Mayo Brains.
Speaker 4: David. Jeremy in origin
here. I love your analogy to these
people's brains in mayonnaise,
because for one, mayonnaise is gross.
Speaker 1: And so I actually I
actually like mayo. I think mayo was great.
Speaker 4: Yeah. And love the pronunciation.
And I didn't have another example of why.
But yes. GROSS And that's a good example.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I didn't come up. I mean, to
be honest, I know some people think that I call
people mayo brained because I think mayonnaise is
gross. I actually love mayonnaise, and I didn't
come up with it. Mayo Brained is just a known
term. You can check it out on Urban Dictionary,
you can check it out elsewhere. I wish I could
take credit for that. I really do, but I genuinely
cannot. We have such a great bonus show for you
today that I think even Alex Jones is going to go
for this one. Thank you. Your lucky stars
every day. You're not David Pakman. Well, okay,
but you can still listen to the bonus show we are
going to talk about. We had this train derailment,
even though train derailment have actually
been declining over the last several decades,
we still have too many. We want to reduce
the number of great. So let's put together
a bill to reduce train derailment. There is a
bipartisan rail safety bill that has been proposed
and it has hit a roadblock. What is the roadblock?
Is it Bernie Sanders? No, the roadblock is
Republicans, which you probably could have
guessed. We will talk about what's in the bill. We
will talk about why Republicans are now getting in
the bill's way. Secondly, Gavin Newsom has decided
that California is not going to do business with
Walgreens over an abortion pill issue. What is the
issue? Is Gavin Newsom still thinking of running
for president or would he only do that if Joe
Biden doesn't run? We're going to talk about all
of it on today's bonus show. And additionally,
there is a lot of discussion about, you know,
if Trump doesn't win the Republican nomination,
he'll run as an independent. And I think it would
be great if he did that. And I think he could
destroy the Republican Party if he did. However,
there are what are colloquially referred to as
sore loser laws in a handful of important states
that would not allow Trump to run third party if
he actually stays in the Republican primary to
the end and loses it. What is a sore loser law?
We know Trump's a sore loser that we that we don't
need to explore. But what is a sore loser law? How
does it work? How could it affect Donald Trump's
ability to run third party? All of those stories
will be on today's bonus show. You can sign up at
join Packman dot com. We have a coupon code. That
code is 24 starts now you can also use the left
over from the weekend code C pac trash if you
thought like I did that C PAC was absolute trash.
You can use the code CPAC trash to get a discount.
Also want to remind you, we are continuing to
scale up the Spanish channel. If you know of
people who would prefer to consume political
content in Spanish rather than English, direct
them with total peace and love and generosity
to David Pakman dot com slash Spanish, We have
surpassed our first couple of thousand subscribers
on that channel. I believe we just have made some
additional improvements to the channel which are
really great. Make sure you are aware of that.
And then lastly, remember the best things you can
do to support our program are all free. Make sure
you subscribe to our podcast on any podcasting
platform you like Stitcher, Pandora, Spotify,
iTunes, Google, whatever. Make sure you're
subscribed to the YouTube channel where we
are pushing towards 2 million subscribers. All
of these things leave a comment, leave a like
leave a review on iTunes. These things cost
nothing and they really do help independent
media. I will see you on the bonus show and
we'll be back tomorrow with a brand new show.